warning the following game contains
flashing lights loud noises and jump
scares this may result in epileptic
seizures when exposed hello everybody
it's time again for another five nights
at freddy's fan game called
juniors
jr junior jr juniors juniors
this one it's kind of weird i've i've
fallen off the trail of following along
with uh five nights at freddy's fan
games because for the most part i didn't
even think that they were still being
made um but this one
people seem to like
so i probably will like it uh go over
the basics yeah i don't know what the
hell i'm doing
i don't know anything about what i'm
doing finding who's possessed check the
security cameras look for flickering
lights or hand prints on the camera lens
mark the possessed character on the
laptop
easy enough
every time you correctly guess a haunted
animatronic via the laptop the ghost
will once again take over an animatronic
suit watch closely for clues like
flickering lights camera outages
handprints and track down the haunted
animatronic
is one of these is one one of these
haunted i really love this style
it's like claymation but not hello
oh
i saw that
when you're ready to click which
animatronic you think is haunted well
oh i don't know about this one you oh
you oh all right fine
whatever guess i can't fail
just too goddamn good one last thing
keeping the robots safe check the
animatronic stability from time to time
call the animatronics to the conveyor
belt for repairs but make sure they're
not haunted
okay wouldn't the haunting need
repairing
duh my hands
what am i doing
whoa
where am i
am i dead
my body this place i seem to be fine but
i feel
empty
i've been scooped
i was in the scooping room i feel as if
i'm being stalked
but this feeling is new to me
can anyone hear me
crunch crunch
crunch
what was that
who's out there
i'm not looking for trouble i just need
to get out of here
please
whoa i've never
kept you i mean i've never seen anything
like that before either
i wouldn't be too happy if i met that in
the middle of the field
great
i really like the art style i really
like it it's whimsical it's adorable
even
hello
hello
oh hi
oh
ah
wha
i'm sorry
i'm sorry
oh this is not
what i anticipated okay um
hello
never mind
hi are you the thing that i met oh
golly i wasn't expecting you to show up
i'm paul bear
great where the hell am i what are you
yeah
where the hell am i
what is this supposed to be
how many faces do you see in the
darkness screaming down at me
oh you're in the barons a limbo between
life and death you got that right
you got that right
world of warcraft flashbacks
i'm dead how's that even possible what
happened to me
slow down there little buddy i said
limbo between life and death don't call
me little you aren't dead at all what
does that even mean it means you can go
back to the real world whenever you want
okay great send me back now i don't
belong here yeah not so fast i brought
you here to help me with some unfinished
business i have in the real world
why can't you just do yourself
unfortunately i'm not alive like you you
i've been trapped in here for as long as
i can remember i've been waiting to
cross paths with someone like you
someone that could help me move on to
the afterlife i'll even make you an
offer you help me with my unfinished
business and i'll lend a helping hand
with your investigation i know junior's
like the back of my hand go over to the
bed i'll transport you back to the real
world meet back here tomorrow night but
that wasn't a lot of instructions also
what's going on back here
and second thought i don't really want
to know about it okay bob i'll go back
oh what are you
carrot craze rules no run x poop
okay
great
i'ma go to
bed now
hi
oh
oh the old familiar places
hello
ah
good
use the cameras to search for haunted
alum animatronics if you see anomalies
such as flickering lights okay i know
all about that open what am i opening
oh
this
is slick uh
[Music]
this one
is it this one oh god oh no where are
you going oh whoa whoa whoa is that you
is that you is that you what do i do
oh
well i'm
concerned i think it's you
whoa no
oh
there's a lot of you i'm gonna die
as is the usual with the oh hi hello
foxy of sorts kind of a little bit
can i close you
i am going to die but i want to know
what i'm doing
no adam tracks are here for repair
that's good
hi
stability
oh no
oh no
oh
uh open your laptop on your left on my
left and report them by holding space
okay um
but about that uh
i'm feeling a little unwell feeling like
death might be encroaching upon me
there's some flickering here but you
just left
i don't know do they just wander around
did they not come near me that'd be
great
i say with confidence
this is super cool oh what did i see up
there what did i what is the green light
up there what is that is that bad is
that good
okay i don't know
okay um
once again
i see something flickering here you seem
but i don't know who you who are who is
you
who is you
i don't even know which one you is
you
ah
all space
ah okay i think you're haunted
i'm confirming
yo yeah
oh god
ah
look around the cameras the spot clue
such as hands but can appear when a
haunted animatronic leaves good okay so
i forgot about the looking for the hand
smudges which is something that i didn't
do
i'll be sure to do that next time great
so foxy was haunted
i don't know why i don't know what
caused that maybe i should have paid
more attention maybe i should have done
a lot of things maybe i should have
finished engineering school maybe i
should have quit while i was ahead
maybe i should have
i don't know you think foxy's still
haunted
a lot of animatronics in this room every
animatronic is in this room oh
interesting huh the ghost has entered an
animation oh so none of you were haunted
initially all right good great good
well two of you are gone
hello god that is the worst chica sleepy
chica ain't my favorite chica i'm i'm
not gonna lie
then these guys zip around
way too much
oh hi
hey
how you doing
oh you're gone are you so what do you
mean by smudges
because the camera feed ain't exactly
good here
there's a lot
a leeway
for me to look
around
oh
foxy
[Music]
might you be
haunted
am i gonna die again
i really hate that
i can't even find foxy
hey bub
hello who are you who are you i don't
even know who you are what is the point
of getting an exo
read out if i don't even know who you
are
not a clue i don't know where foxy's is
but i'm gonna guess foxy
maybe
i knew it
oh of course god i hate that drawing
that is
bonnie was haunted of course we all knew
this this was the only possibility out
of this if the lights are flickering in
a camera i can't tell if the lights are
flickering in a camera or if the camera
feed is flickering when they move so i
gotta look for that i know i'm being
extremely stupid but it's my strategy i
start off stupid and then hit them with
my intelligence when they least expect
it it's when you least expect it too
cause you never expect it and then
suddenly boom i'm smart
and what do you think about that i don't
think anything because my brain don't
work when will the ghost enter the ammo
also what is the ghost that seems like
awfully convenient that the ghost will
always haunt something i mean
inconvenient but can you inconvenient
for me finding it consistently and
justifying my job
hello sleepy okay there's a lot of you
know the lights
i gotta lie that seemed like some
flickering and i i didn't see any other
animatronics there
where'd you go sleepy oh sleepy go bye
where are you stay in one spot there you
are sleepy you tuckered
it seems to be that i mean it
you know it
i mean is that
it seemed like it
ooh
[Music]
i got it
use down time wisely
all right let's call the oh whoops oh i
thought it i thought i could i thought i
could call all of them in there
i thought
that's not good
oh that's not good
okay so i think i got it
here anyway
okay so use downtime wisely i don't
really know what the down time is
supposed to be
oh no another ghost
so
the light thing was helpful
oh
something's flickering you again are you
serious are you serious you haunted
again
are you haunted again is you haunted
you're looking right at me you is
haunted ain't you i thought you were
going in for a pair but no you just
haunted all over again
it's so it's so
it's so cheeky again 100
got sleepy ghost here
all right you know what you know what
none of the other ones are
having any effect on the surrounding
seems to be all you
wherever you are
where did you go
oh
well okay now
oh oh oh which one is it
oh which one is it it started really
getting
all kind of jittery when you walked in
the room
is this oh it's still it's still it's a
hundred percent yeah no way 100 100 it's
that hundred hundred percent 100
done
damn i'm good see it only took a few
failures and then my intelligence popped
out my investigation is complete
paul bear is waiting for you
paul bear like the pallbearer of a
coffin
is gonna dance me to my grave
[Music]
great this is kind of cool you know i'm
not gonna lie this is a little this is a
unique spin on this and i do enjoy it
who is pallbearer
and also why am i investigating anything
at all
i don't know
why would i know i don't know anything
i'm a fool
but i'm a fool for you
[Music]
i'm sorry
hello it's me again hey what's up gang
hey what's up anything new here anything
new more rules still poop okay cool
hey paul bear you came back so i had
your first night go i died a few times
it was unlike anything i had ever seen
the paranormal activity was off the
charts as i suspected the same ghost has
been haunting juniors for years playing
the same old tricks wait if there's a
ghost in the real world then why can't
you do this yourself you made that whole
thing up last night
all right fine he caught me i lied and
he ghost can go back to the real world
but i'm such a nervous wreck i i can't
go back i've been hiding in this costume
for so long a ghost afraid of ghosts
yeah a little bit yeah that's kind of
why i need you i'm tired i'm tired of
being afraid of her she won't let me
leave with my soul intact she'd rip me
to itty bitty pieces if she knew i was
hiding out here with you
but now that you're here you can help me
by getting rid of the ghost once and for
all yeah i'm not sure about this one i
feel like a fish on a hook no no no no
no you're right let's talk more tomorrow
night
i was right about what i'm a fish on a
hook is that what i'm right about
because i don't want to be right about
that thing that sounds like the thing
that i don't want to be right about why
would i want to be right about a hello
welcome back me how you doing me good
great thanks me hello
no ghosts yet huh why are you looking at
me why you looking at me
don't look at me that's what i thought
oh oh
what hey who
who's playing pranks who's who's a
prankster who's doing it you was it you
you only have one hand and that is a
left hand which would equate technically
speaking to the hand that you
would have done
okay so if you leave
and there's a handprint here
i know for sure is
you my boy
interesting
yes yes yes
oh any hand print no
no oh
a handprint's gone here which is
interesting
okay we got bonnie we got foxy we got
the two of them in the kitchen no
handprint left behind okay now that is
interesting
i don't know if just this time is going
to be the handprint time
hello
hello
who fret freddy fred fred fred freddy
lights are kind of i think that's just
the
tv scan
it's freddy
oh it's so freddy at least they're not
coming after me
freddy you get your butt in here
oh
yeah all right i think i'm good here
i use downtime wisely
uh should i call him in for repair
i
i thought that it would send them down
to the the
conveyor belt and it would
i would need to repair them i i wasn't
briefed on any needs to repair oh no a
ghost has entered the animatronic
but he's freddie's not out of play
though is he
what is that what was the thunkin all
about
why is the music very loud here music
didn't used to be that loud over there
interesting
interesting why is music so loud here
why would music be so loud here
hello what are you two doing here oh oh
foxy is that you
oh is it you
is it true
man why are you all the way down here
oh yeah
but also it seems like it didn't it
didn't really do anything i
i can't really send him in for repair is
he there oh he is there oh god oh my god
grab the chip from inside and toss it
out in the freddy faz baby you're right
grab a new chip from the left i hate
this is awful
grab a new chip okay i'm good we're all
good oh boy
oh boy and freddie's back baby
all right good
let's see if you leave a handprint
did someone else
jump in here
someone no
i don't see a handprint
oh hi foxy you wanna
see if you can leave a handprint
okay so if he leaves a handprint there
oh no handprint
has anybody got a handprint
anybody leaving a handprint
okay i'm gonna lose it on this one and i
don't like that i don't like any of this
freddie you're in here no one else is in
here where did everybody go
where is everybody i don't know they're
gonna lose stability and i'm gonna die
aren't i
okay bonnie what about you
what about you bonbon
no not the monster but you're there
whoever you are
i don't know
uh
hi foxy
i don't
i don't know who it is
i'm at a loss
i i am
uh
chica is it you oh
handprint no yes no oh no what do i do
wait no hold on stop this is not fair am
i going do i need to go by lights again
i was i was in handprint mode i wasn't
even aware of the idea of lights i
wasn't even thinking about lights are
kind of
no no no they're that's just the normal
am i stupid am i dumb am i dumb i might
be dumb
i'm i'm dumb where even are any of them
and don't say to my left they're all
gone uh
chica is it you
oh freak oh freak okay
oh frick oh frick
oh frick somebody please
i'm gonna guess chica i i i don't even
i'm just gonna guess his guess is guess
i'm gonna die this is how i die oh god
what is that about
what is that about
are you even in here are you even in
here what is that is that is that a sign
i'm trusting it my gut yes
i don't even know where that thing was
i didn't even know that thing could be a
thing but i used my brain
i used my big brain and i solved my way
through it
i'm incredible
i'm unbelievable i'm outstanding
every part of me
amazing
but also why am i doing this what is
that all about after finishing your
shift you stumble across an old vhs tape
so of course i watch it
who knows what might be there what home
movie someone might have made at some
point in the past and put there i
wouldn't want anyone else to see you
watch it of course
i'm watching it
hope it's not anything unsavory
oh
that is adorable
[Music]
uh
the oh beware the mangle
interesting that this is a vhs tape
some make a home movie or something uh
so who's filming
why was it mangle crotch pov
i don't like that i don't like any part
of that
the mangle i don't know look i don't
know man i don't know i don't know
anything about this i don't know
anything that's happening here i don't
know what's going on and i don't need to
know what's going on everything's a
mystery and that's okay
that's fine
hey
how you doing good to see you
hey buddy how'd it go it went well i
found something that you might want to
know about now what's on your mind oops
i found a vhs tape a vhs tape yeah i
stumbled across it after my shift i
think i was trying to give him give us a
message a message about what not sure
yet it was just an old school cartoon
episode something about it was very off
well how'd the tape end with freddy
carrying a piece of an animatronic to a
door that said
the mangle
a mangle of parts why would the ghost
need animatronic parts and maybe the
ghost is building a new body she's
building the mangle
the mangle huh i don't like the sound of
that let's see if the next tape will
help us i'll talk to you after good luck
buddy thanks buddy
thanks pal
thanks amigo
okay good back to my nightly duties if i
don't know what the hell i'm doing
hi how y'all doing you good
you good
looking good you feeling good
great
man you guys are really active
i think i think what i probably have to
do is i got to be more on top of
actually repairing people and getting
them in and doing the chip thing
which means that i gotta get to finding
the uh
the ghostly animatronics sooner
a little dingy in here
all right so if there's a if there's a
paw print or something like that
afterwards
or a hook scratch
then i know that it's foxy
nothing that i see there no
print there
uh
what about this
nope i don't see nobody with conveyor
belt controls that's kind of interesting
hey bud keep an eye on the camera stand
i know some strange movement with them
what do you mean
what do you mean
what do you mean
strange movement i'm not seeing enough
movement
i'm not seeing any movement at all oh
is it you fred bear oh that's all right
so i'm just gonna take a guess that that
was fredbear he was making the cameras
all wibbly oh my god i'm so good
excellent all right you get in there let
me look at the conveyor belt oh that's
that's really slow
all right so there's a few different
ways that these guys might actually
be
messing with me but they're not here yet
man there's no way that i'm gonna be
able to oh what did you did you just did
you just
okay hold on i'll be right with you
okay uh
take that there you go and i oh it's all
good to go
let's check this first see if anything
is weird nope seems good here
stability is a little
suspect
okay no missed camera control yet
oh is that a handprint okay that that
doesn't mean that it was you that left
that
okay you're looking at me i don't trust
any time when they're looking at me you
know what i mean i don't like that i
don't like that about you
and you know what else
i got a funny feeling that the only way
that you could have done that
oh never mind it's foxy so i'm gonna
call
you in i just oh i'm an idiot i'm dumb
boom but also god i'm dumb i really did
not think that one through ah that was
just about as bad as it could have gone
okay let's see if i can quickly get this
please
please let me in
oh god please i'll take that take that
here go
give me another one
please tell me no uh i did it
oh i think i just missed it i think i
just avoided it
oh don't like when they look at me
see that's foxy yeah yeah yeah
okay
oh there's a smudge here who's in the
smudge you chica
could it be
oh it was chica i think it was chica i'm
pretty sure if not i'm boned
i'm boned oh god no not like this i'm
going in here you can't get me in here
don't
do
anything to me ever please
i'm too young to die
i'm am i dead am i my head oh
the marion i see i didn't know that the
marionette was even in here yeah i
didn't even listen for the puppet's
lullaby to know what
what
huh
did you know that that was a thing i did
i did not know that was a thing
okay all right well um now i know
i don't like that i know but i know
uh i'm gonna call you in because if i
call someone right away this is pro
strats if i call someone in right away
then they can't possibly be the ghost so
therefore by process of removability
they
it'll be better for that than me
i think that's a pro strat and advanced
very advanced
you're
okay ghost has entered the animatronic
but i have to enter the repair shop
there you go give give
all right so who's the ghost
so what what i probably gotta do
eventually is i gotta get good enough to
know who's not oh oh someone in here
who's doing it who's doing it who's
doing it who's doing it who's doing it
wow oh that doesn't tell me any goddamn
news who's done it
who's was dozen who did it who done it
who did that god damn it which one of it
was you
uh
wild guess g cup
i never lose when i guess
i'm i lose
oh
does that even count does it count if i
get does that count am i dead am i dead
or alive am i dead i feel dead but i
feel alive are you you get it get in
here chica i guess
i don't know i guess i'm fine i'm i'm
fine
i've never been more fine how did that
happen in work
i don't know
a ghost has entered an animatronic uh
gross didn't need to know that all right
so there's a bunch of different ways
that i could learn uh i need to repair
someone though because you're there
no one's glitching out here but chica is
in bad need of repair
all right good
all right who's here
freddy what's up what's up bub
you look fine
you're fine it ain't freddy which means
that i can bring freddie in
let's bring freddie in because
definitely not freddie
100
huh
what is that all about that's weird
don't like that
oh who's in here who who's in here who's
in here oh music music that means i know
what that means that means
yes
the marionette right
oh my god i'm so good
gif yeah take that these chips we go
through them all right i got to call
multiple people in eventually i am not
doing too great man yeah i do got to get
ahead of it a bit more someone's got to
be like coming in every single moment
yeah almost okay
ghost has entered animatronic that's
interesting
love that
okay no one there i was just looking for
numbers to freak out oh god i don't have
time i don't have time i'm just gonna
hope that it's not the marionette twice
in a row that would really suck and
really ruin my day
okay you're all in here one of you left
no handprint
okay
no no
no
you're really gonna make the marionette
haunted twice in a row just be just a
screw with me
just just just screw with me you're
really gonna get me to run around with
that you're gonna pull a fast one on me
like that you're gonna you're gonna give
me the business like that you're gonna
give me the business you're gonna give
me the business like that why would you
give me the business like that all right
i gotta call someone in
uh you
i should probably call one of the ones
that are not funky
like uh one of the the marionette or
whatever the other one is i don't even
know what it is
the ghost has entered damage right good
good good i'll get back to it later
come on how long does it take
okay
so the sound is boom
that's real spooky like
okay who we got who we got
okay
i'm not seeing it oh who's it who do it
who did okay so it's either foxy or
chica it must be chica it must be chica
because foxy was in
the repair
exactly just like that call someone
right away around that
feels good to be good
starting to understand
i see
give
i hate that you're there
all right who is it
looking for signs two of you in here
this is a good option
oh
all right did you just move or did you
did you just change places or did you
decide it anyway whatever
all right so no hand print there if
there's a hand print when i come back
that's foxy
is the one for sure
okay chica's there alone nope not alone
okay not foxy
at least not by handprint status
these two here oh chica just left oh god
damn it one of them just left okay so
it's either chica or
bonnie so i can call in freddy at the
very least
damn you damn you of course you would
of course you would
where are you okay so there's chica she
just left nothing there's bonnie must be
bonnie
must be bonnie absolutely must be
must be bonnie
hand print
no
oh
hate that
why would you do that to me
why would you do that
oh you
bastard oh you suck so it's i know it's
between the two of them so i can call
one of these guys in i know it's between
the two of them i just don't know which
one whoa what was that
what did i just see
hello
okay so
cheek is there
chica just left left a hand print that's
it that's all i need to know
oh frick freak you
okay i'm calling in you
oh okay so long as you stay on top of
everything everything is going to be
okay
that's how this goes
so next i need to get chica and a
balloon well balloon boy's coming in
chica and then foxy
ghost is entering animatronic
good to know
oh who's in here it's freddy that was
easy
okay it's uh it's freddy
good for me
give oh what are wrong with you
okay i'm calling in chica
and then foxy's next
getting good at this
this is quite fun i like the game loop
it's good it's investigative it feels
like i'm actually puzzling it out i have
a reason to go to all the cameras i do
enjoy that that is the worst freddy
costume ever
i
hate that
okay where is everyone all right so
someone's here okay so oh that was the
marionette in the uh
in the uh other room let me just see if
any of this is freaking out nope
so why was the marionette in
why is the marionette in here
you doing anything
oh oh oh no one of them it's either foxy
or chica okay who's it who's it who's
this who's is
who's is it's one of yous it's one of
yous
okay was it chica seems to be working
fine now
i can't confirm that
i cannot confirm or deny that
need another sign foxy you gonna mess
with the camera again foxy
now i have no idea
oh my god it's one or the other oh frick
oh this is a pain in the ass
oh who is it who's it foxy oh you're
both in here why are you both in here
okay it's it it started being okay when
i think it's chica because it just left
and it's fine
oh god oh god go go go oh my god
oh
[Music]
i don't like that i don't like that at
all i don't like the close call of it i
don't even know if i'm still okay i
might still be dead but i don't like it
i don't like it at all
get over here
[Music]
oh my god bonnie also
not looking so good
all right which one of you
which one of you just make it easy
please
bonnie or is it
the marionette
oh it's bonnie okay cool thank you you
made it easy thank you
oh
all right
good great
oh i need to get better about i need to
get better about um
about freaking doing the freaking thing
before not knowing who knowing who is
not it that's what i need to know
and that way i can start getting people
into repair sooner
after finishing your shift you stumble
across an old vhs tape
the curiosity is eating at you but you
don't know if you should watch it or not
well
i don't know
should i watch it or should i not
or should i
save it until the next episode
[Laughter]
i really like this i wanna i wanna keep
playing it um but i'm out of time to
record this episode so uh if you guys
want to see more of this let me know
down in the comments below thank you
more five nights at freddy's through the
link hey did you know i have a podcast
did you know i have two go my favorite
port
lixie and texas beats that better than i
did go my favorite sportster and
distractible go check them out links are
in the description you'll love them i
guarantee you thank you and as always
i'll see you
in the next video
bye-bye
[Music]
you